今日部肇社長って皆さん youtube 使ってますか
使ってないと見れねーかベルシーいうツールを使ってますか日々ね
youtube を進化していってさまざまの木の場合もほっ使えるようになっていっ
てるんですけども
字幕機能というのが使えるようになっておりまして
基本的に僕のさんに出会った僕はに縫合かちょっと英語を喋るか滑舌悪くてたまに
ベンガル語しゃべり日くらいなんですけども
どんだけ日本日本人の人しか見れないような動画なんですよなんですけど今の
ユーチューバー死んだしたことで今で全生活費とか youtube 武力不可能に
なってそれはなぜかというと youtube の動画に字幕が付いているかでござい
ます例えばなんですけどこの動画をですね
こうにあるんですよ字幕っていうことなんでいまだ度も2つれている中国語台湾台湾と
に
今後が付いてますこの中国語にすると
[音楽]
1分
ほらほらちゃんと寝ちゃんだねここに字幕が出るんですよこの字幕があるのでもうね
日本人だけじゃなくてよね社外の人がこの僕の動画を見ることができるということに
なっておりますすごくないですか
字幕があることによっても世界中の人がね僕の意味不明のよくわかんねぇ動画を楽しむ
ことができるという画期的な時代に来てるわけなんですけどもう字幕ようですね
どうだってついているかといいますとこれね誰でも少なく作れるんですよだれでも簡単
に僕の動画で字幕をつけることができるようになっております特に最近だと台湾の方が
よく字幕をつけてくださっています
台湾の人ありがとうバン語でありがとうってなんだよ同社
しまったというわけでは自爆舞台でも作れるんですけどもここでだ字幕というのはね
まあもちろん日本語の字幕をつけるわけなんですけども
聞いた話によるとオイラーの動画の日本語の条件非常におかしいという話を聞いたこと
があるので今後ちょっとそれを見ていこうと思います裏基本字幕つけないから日本語
設定で見ていきましょう
昨日の動画です道
他に稼働
[音楽]
後にその
glaz 暑がっはっはーんっ
ん
5が
ならばならなかった
三島つけてくれてるんだねー
びっくりだよ
[音楽]
弊社笑ってないでしょすばらってないようには狙ったり詰まったぞとか今鶏笑ってて
いいからね
完全でこれ完全にあたり笑ってるでしょそういうことか
[音楽]
イエスは貯蓄が降っていますこれこれ
ap ペペちょっと初のマダラをしてくれてるんですねえぺんぺんほしい
すごいだよく日本語安ありがたい
[音楽]
工程4
からされ
言葉にしてほら後生理とか全部で台詞を
セリフを全部ちゃんとねあげてくれてるねこれもこれはミッションに頭に置いておき
ますとか
すごいよ本当にありがたい必要
いや面白いのもいいけどこういうしっかり作ってる奴もありますね
[音楽]
いい数同じ人かいい
うわぁ
[音楽]
ここではずずあんまり売ってね気がするんですけど
はじめの姫入りましたありがとうございます
[音楽]
アップブーツちょっと雑魚れざると杖でイベでポッポけって
だからポッポ木言ってるけどね
[音楽]
クオン水の鳴き声が湖水の鳴き声がざっくりされている
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ